près de deux Français sur 10 en
souffrent coût de projecteur ce soir sur
l'obésité dans un instant notre invité
nous parlera d'un parcours de prise en
charge unique en France mais d'abord
l'obésité au quotidien le handicap
physique et le regard des autres et des
tours en gel témoignent au micro
d'Aurélie Renaud deuxième épisode de
notre rubrique santé au quotidien toute
cette semaine
de lentilles corail aux pois chiches et
rouleaux de printemps aujourd'hui le
menu est vegan un atelier pour cuisiner
léger mais surtout pour échanger sur ce
qui lit les participants le surpoids
l'obésité il y a pas de jugement
évidemment enfin voilà donc c'est c'est
très convivial et puis chacun amène ses
petites histoires les petites
problématiques qu'il a pu rencontrer
comment on les vire on l'a c'est pas
tout à fait le moment mais on a aussi
des groupes de paroles etc et c'est la
plus là qu'on échange en fait
l'association poids formés bien-être
propose aussi de la marche de la
natation et des cours de
socio-esthétiques il s'agit de lutter
contre l'isolement pour certains sortir
boire un café en ville relève du défi
c'est vrai que quand on va des endroits
on regarde toujours s'il y a des
endroits pour s'asseoir parce qu'on
fatigue plus vite et si il y a de la
place pour nous parce qu'on prend plus
de
parce que c'est pas évident de de
rencontrer les autres quand on est un
peu diminué quand on n'est pas à la même
hauteur que les autres
je trouve que ben il faut toujours se
moi je dis moi je me bats tout le temps
voilà parce que c'est le regard des
autres qui fait que Ben en s'isole voilà
et c'est la peur du regard des autres le
manque de bienveillance de la part des
inconnus fait partie du quotidien mais
les réflexions blessantes peuvent
également venir de certains médecins
effectivement
très qui est le phénomène qui qui marque
le plus et qui revient le plus dans les
groupes de parole des
adhérents qui sont victimes à chaque
fois de réflexion de la part des
médecins quoi qu'il leur disent oui mais
si on doit vous opérer faut maigrir et
tout ça alors qu'on sait que maintenant
on sait que le surpoids est une maladie
chronique dans quelques jours les
membres de l'association proposeront un
vide dressing grande taille car bon
nombre de magasins de prêt-à-porter
n’habillent pas les personnes en
surpoids